[Música]
la cámara baja de eeuu aprobó dos
proyectos de ley que buscan regularizar
a millones de indocumentados en su
mayoría jóvenes conocidos como trimmers
y a trabajadores agrícolas esto coincide
con el aumento en la llegada a ciudades
estadounidenses limítrofes con mexico de
miles de menores de edad provenientes de
centroamérica
estados unidos y china- realizaron su
primer encuentro durante la era byte en
beijing advierte medidas firmes a
injerencias de la unión americana y
llamó a abandonar la mentalidad de la
guerra fría mientras washington acusó a
los chinos de adoptar acciones que
amenazan el orden mundial y la
estabilidad global
y continuamos con nuestra serie de
informes tras cumplirse 10 años de las
protestas de las protestas que derivaron
en una cruenta guerra civil en siria
desde el inicio del conflicto cerca de
5.6 millones de personas han huido del
país hoy vamos hasta mexico donde una
organización humanitaria ha acogido a
jóvenes sirios para que puedan continuar
sus estudios y su vida fuera del peligro
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 fibra blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en eeuu donde la cámara de
representantes controlada por el
oficialismo demócrata aprobó dos
proyectos de ley de reforma migratoria
que buscan regularizar a millones de
indocumentados en su mayoría los jóvenes
llamados trimmers y los trabajadores
agrícolas este intento de regularización
migratoria coincide con el fuerte
aumento de la llegada de miles de
menores de edad no acompañados de
centroamérica lo que ha servido para que
gran parte de la oposición rechace los
proyectos aprobados previamente
conversamos con nuestro corresponsal en
washington dice cristóbal vázquez quien
nos contó a que deben enfrentarse ahora
estos dos proyectos aprobados en la
cámara de representantes y las
posibilidades de prosperar en el senado
esto fue lo que nos dijo
se enfrentará a una barrera bastante
alta los demócratas tienen en este
momento la mayoría en el senado con
kamala harris que actúa como presidente
del senado y pues de a los demócratas el
voto número 51 la mayoría simple sin
embargo lo que muchos analistas están
diciendo y varios senadores es que se va
a aplicar la acción del filibustero es
decir los republicanos que son minoría
van a obstruir el voto a poner un
bloqueo a pedir que se necesiten 60
votos y no una mayoría simple para que
estas dos proyectos de ley que fueron
aprobados en la cámara de representantes
pues sean aprobados en la cámara alta el
filibusterismo era una acción que usaban
antes los senadores donde obstruían el
voto a través de discursos eternos
discursos muy largos para evitar
precisamente la votación pero en este
momento simplemente el philip bester
pues se hace a través de un correo así
que un correo de parte de algún
republicano obligaría a los 60 votos y
no a la mayoría simple
y es que también continúa el drama de
los menores migrantes en eeuu el
gobierno biden admitió que son más de
14.000 los niños que han atravesado
solos la frontera hacia eeuu y ahora se
encuentran bajo custodia de agencias
gubernamentales estadounidenses pese a
las críticas de los republicanos la casa
blanca volvió a negarse a calificar la
situación de crisis y añadió que a
diferencia de la administración trump
actualmente estados unidos no está
expulsando a menores no acompañados para
analizar este tema nos acompaña
irineo mujica director de la ong pueblo
sin fronteras señor mujica gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 muy
buen día le pregunto cuál es el panorama
para estos 14.000 menores es decir que
ya están bajo custodia de las agencias
estadounidenses que les esperan
pues la gran mayoría de ellos van a
tener que ahorita están tratando de
procesarlos usualmente los procesa los
estaban tomando muchos de los casos que
estaban siendo cuando estaba en la era
de trump más sin embargo ahorita había
25.000 personas esperando en el pp y
ahora con la pandemia y todo ahora que
ya están en los eeuu las cortes van a
tener que decidir más sin embargo ha
sido el primer proceso ha sido
supuestamente muy difícil de ponerlos
con los familiares o también por ejemplo
este que las organizaciones que están de
ayuda a los migrantes realmente no
llegan se quedan en el vip y ahora pues
está esperando a ver qué es lo que va a
pasar la mayoría de ellos pues no
deberían estar en la casa es realmente
una lástima que en esta administración
todavía se encuentren los niños siendo
encarcelados tienen que tener por ley
solamente 72 horas lo cual no se cumple
y pues esperemos que encontremos la
manera si eeuu puede deportar miles y
miles de migrantes creo que también
podría de alguna manera no tener a los
lados
en cárceles formó por más tiempo de lo
que es necesario y yo vaivén prometió y
mucho del electorado quien los estados
unidos incluso incluso mi persona
votamos por un cambio de de donald trump
se tiene que cumplir hecho ninguna de
las promesas más fuertes esta migración
una reforma migratoria ahora esperemos
que la pase pero pero realmente estos
niños todavía enfrentan un infierno en
lugares porque los mismos oficiales que
estuvieron anteriormente a cargo o sea
no quiere digo digo que realmente son
los que los que siguen a cargo de esta
situación ahora una de las cifras que
revela la casa blanca es que desde
octubre 2020 han sido detenidos unos
29.000 menores no acompañados y que
cientos de ellos son menores de 12 años
qué significa que sean detenidos son
diferentes a estos 14.000 de los que
hablamos antes
pues o sea los que están los que están
detenidos no son tantos están deteniendo
aproximadamente lo más grande que había
escuchado yo eran cuatro mil por mes lo
cual o sea estás hablando de 44 mil
niños que tienen que ser procesados en
el sistema a la situación pues o sea se
agrava supuestamente porque o sea es
normal es del número de de flujo hasta
cierto punto hay diferentes factores que
los están llevando a ellos la violencia
el final de la pandemia los huracanes
todo eso ha hecho que que suban un poco
aparte de que puesto o sea tienes una
máquina parada y ahora esta máquina
vuelve a comenzar con ahora con baile
que es una de las cuestiones o sea con
con las nuevas políticas realmente no ha
cambiado simplemente volvieron las cosas
como estaban pero estuvo años o sea
rezagados e empujado y así también en
méxico existen las condiciones porque en
méxico también pasaron leyes que dicen
que las personas no pueden tener a los
migrantes en centros de detención o sea
porque también son horribles los centros
en méxico o sea los niños siguen siendo
encarcelados ahora con esta ley en
méxico también los niños ahora pues de
alguna manera éste no tiene en méxico la
capacidad y muchas veces son dejados ir
hacia la mano hacia la frontera por
alguna alguna razón méxico también este
pues no sé cómo es con moneda de cambio
también también le conviene hasta ahora
hacer el gobierno biden asegura que está
devolviendo a mexico a adultos solos y
familias qué pasa con ellos en su país
de origen
y lo que pasa en el lugar de origen o
sea lo que más está sacando a los niños
son los factores en muchos de ellos los
niños que vienen osea no realmente
vienen solo vienen con un adulto muchas
veces por ejemplo me tocan los casos que
tenemos dos albergues y los hermanos por
ejemplo a veces vienen hermano mayor y
al hermano menor y son separados y no
son familia inmediata son dejados o sea
por los niños son se quedan también si
no puedes demostrar algún tipo de
parentesco que sea fuerte o sea también
no sean o no es o sea si los niños son
muy pequeños me imagino que ha de ser
diferente pero los que yo he visto los
separan realmente los separan porque no
son o sea no son familiares como el mamá
o la papa digo los padres especialmente
y está en otra de las cosas es la
violencia la de las maras para reclutar
niños o sea de muy muy pequeña edad para
que cometan crímenes y pues las leyes
hacen que estos niños no sean castigados
de la misma manera que un adulto y son
más fáciles objetos
para esto y la pobre ande los huracanes
la familia
se nos acaba el tiempo lamentablemente
lo tengo que despedir gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 nosotros seguimos en eeuu
íbamos hasta alaska donde se celebró el
primer día de una tensa reunión de alto
nivel entre diplomáticos chinos y
estadounidenses washington acusó a los
chinos de grandilocuencia por estar
enfocados en lo que llamaron el teatro
político y público y el drama en lugar
de lo que realmente importa mientras que
villena amenazó con acciones firmes
contra la supuesta injerencia de eeuu y
llamó a abandonar la mentalidad de la
guerra fría desde beijing nuestro
corresponsal adrián foncillas nos amplía
cuál es el nuevo tono de la diplomacia
entre estas ambas potencias
ha sido un tono incluso más áspero de lo
que se había pronosticado baiden
prometió que sería duro y además eeuu
aprobó en las vísperas las sanciones a
funcionarios chinos por la reciente
reforma electoral así que china acudió a
alaska preparado para intercambio de
golpes y reproches eeuu en su primera
intervención
efe
en sus políticas en xinjiang hong kong y
taiwán asuntos que son sagrados para
china beijing por su parte acusó a eeuu
de utilizar su poderío económico y
militar para intentar imponer su
voluntad en todo el mundo ambos países
se acusaron mutuamente de utilizar un
tono arrogante y de romper los
protocolos pactados ha sido un
intercambio agrio pero que contentará a
ambas audiencias internas a china le
servirá para mostrar a su pueblo que ya
es capaz de abofetear eeuu a domicilio
mientras que a bailén le servirá para
refutar la teoría que asegura que es un
tibio y que solo trump era capaz de
poner en cintura a china las
conversaciones ya sin focos han
continuado y según fuentes periodísticas
han sido productivas la cumbre terminará
mañana y si no hay cambio de última hora
lo hará sin declaración conjunta para
subrayar todavía más las diferencias que
separan ambos países
marruecos entra en la lista de países
que buscan legalizar el uso del cannabis
medicinal el país africano aprobó un
proyecto de ley que pretende regular el
cultivo y la comercialización de la
marihuana la propuesta pretende impulsar
la economía del país y poner freno al
narcotráfico naciones incluidas varias
de américa latina como chile perú y
méxico- inclusión en el debate sobre la
legalización de la planta para su uso
terapéutico y también industrial
encaminados a la legalización tras una
semana de la aprobación del proyecto de
ley que permite la producción
exportación y el uso de cannabis con
fines terapéuticos en marruecos los
cultivadores consideran por primera vez
salir de la ilegalidad
la temporada de cosecha se lleva a cabo
en junio y julio y el proceso de
transformación es hachís empieza en
septiembre el traficante de drogas viene
a comprar la producción del agricultor
ofreciendo el precio que él quiere el
agricultor es pobre y la planta es lo
único que crece aquí porque hace
demasiado frío la tierra no es apta para
cereales no es lo suficientemente fértil
tenemos pequeñas parcelas de tierra a
través del proyecto de ley el gobierno
pretende organizar a los cultivadores en
cooperativas y sancionar a quienes
distribuyan la planta por fuera del
circuito oficial
tenemos miedo como agricultores y
pedimos que se establezcan industrias
que transformen el cannabis para su
consumo médico e industrial y que se
establezcan fábricas para emplear mano
de obra local y la pese a las divisiones
políticas que ha generado el proyecto de
ley el parlamento deberá ratificar la
decisión del ejecutivo antes
legislativas de septiembre con 47 mil
hectáreas de marihuana sembrada en las
montañas del rif marruecos es uno de los
principales productores de marihuana en
el mundo según la agencia antidrogas de
la onu
seguimos con nuestra serie sobre los
refugiados sirios por el mundo a
propósito de los 10 años del inicio de
la cruenta guerra civil en cydia la
historia de hoy es en mexico una
organización humanitaria ha acogido a
jóvenes sirios para que puedan continuar
sus estudios y su vida fuera del peligro
nuestro corresponsal almario carbonell
nos tiene la historia
veamos
soy decir ya tengo 27 años su nombre
árabe es abdel qader pero prefiere usar
su nombre curso lleva 4 años en méxico
donde llegó después de haber pasado un
tiempo en irak cuando escapó de siria
tras padecer la violencia de la guerra
este cazador chocolate me pasó un
disparo en mi pecho
este fue razón más fuerte que mi familia
me obligó que ayer del país porque ya
estaba muy pero a mi vida aunque dejé mi
estudio qué lástima pero éste fue
obligado a
salva mi vida aprendió español en
aguascalientes y luego pudo seguir sus
estudios de administración de empresas
en monterrey con un sistema y un idioma
ajenos lo que lo hizo muy difícil
la vía para que pudiera continuar su
formación fue la organización proyecto
hub esa que contacta a sirios exiliados
en situación humanitaria crítica y les
ofrece una oportunidad de méxico tenemos
convenio actualmente con 20
universidades alrededor de todo el país
hemos recibido a 21 estudiantes en total
y de estos 21 4 se han graduado y este
diciembre de 2021 regresan también a una
camada si no me equivoco como seis
estudiantes más
sabella apoya a los jóvenes no sólo en
sus estudios también nos acompaña en su
regularización migratoria y en el
proceso de adaptación al país
nos enseñó un paquete de cultura de
idiomas de comida de gente de
comunicación mi facebook me facilitó
muchísimo estos conceptos de la gente de
la cultura que me agregó muchas cosas
mientras estaba en mi primer año aquí en
aguascalientes aunque le encanta méxico
ya que está decidido a volver un día a
su país aportar la experiencia adquirida
y contribuir a la reconstrucción
hasta que el informativo continúe con
nosotros buen día
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde